for three hours French president  Emmanuel macron debated Europe's future  with M EPS and Commission President  jean-claude Juncker he promoted European  sovereignty in the face of national  isolationism MEP urged Facebook Chief  Mark Zuckerberg to come to the European  Parliament to answer questions on the  misuse of the personal data of 2.7  million European Facebook users MEP s  approved more than 50 reports closing  the European Union's 2016 financial year  they welcomed the lowest error rate in  ten years by 2035 65% of municipal waste  should be recycled compared to 44% now  MEP s voted in a new law on the circular  economy which will also reduce landfill  at least 40 people died during the  latest chemical attacks in Syria  Parliament president Antonio Tajani said  that the use of chemical weapons  represents a red line that cannot be  crossed with impunity  [Music]